i want to get better at pen spins again
i just do it with muscle memory now i
don't even think about it i just i hold
a pen and i just i just start doing it i
used to be able to do that one and then
the one we flick it and then it goes and
it goes back yeah yeah i can't do it
anymore i can only tie one
[ __ ]
[Music]
how many like useless skills have you
ever learned in your life
it's just my entire life
my entire life is a list of useful
skills every video game ever every video
game ever i think one day what counts as
a useful skill i don't know i'd like
like okay okay so like the reason i
learned pen spinning is cause i fidget
like i i guess we just started but the
reason i learned pen spinning is because
i just really like to fidget as you guys
know yeah so i thought to myself if i
fidget all the time might as well make
it look cool you know and that's
literally the reason i learned how to do
the pen spin thing
i just did it i just did it because i
was bored in class
otherwise i'd probably just like start
chewing on the pen or something right i
don't know i was like i was definitely
that kid what about like the people who
liked uh felix does this with the knives
nice yeah i wanna i wanna you can't
really bring a knife to school can you
yeah how do you even hate each other how
do you learn and get into that and then
start doing it way too scared to try
it's it's not about learning getting
into that because there's so many
youtube channels that you know teach
that kind of stuff but it's having the
commitment to be like i'm going to learn
this now i'm going to spend time
learning this skill which i don't ever
know if i'm getting a you know gonna be
able to use this in my life right oh
again what's a skill that's useful
actually why did you learn how to solve
a rubik's cube
because i've always just wanted to
because again you know imagine you're
the only asian kid in a white school
right so you're just like given these
like insane expectations to do these
like crazy skills right like people
people never believed me in school when
they said that i couldn't play chess
just because they were like but you're
you're the asian kid you're the smart
kid you should you should know how to do
all these things like you can't play
shogi you can't play go i'm like no it's
like what vacation
and so and rubik's cubes of it like
stereotypically right
yeah back when i was in school yeah by
the way welcome to trash chase we just
we just jumped right into it
yeah i'm connor featuring the boys
yeah the ruby skew player the rubik's
cube
and like i always like because it was
one of those things that i feel you go
to like any house right and there's like
a high possibility that it's just kind
of like sitting there as like an
ornament yeah right i was like very i'd
say like
out of 10 houses that have a rubik's
cube nine of them probably have like a
thin layer of dust on top of it because
it's just like oh it's just like a cool
little knick-knack to put on the shelf
right so yeah to make my it's like that
it's like that coffee table book you
know that like no one actually reads
when it's like oh you read this and
they're like yeah yeah it's like iconic
yeah i don't know it's like a piece is
it but like how often do you get to flex
your rubik's cube skills if it's not
like if i really interested if we didn't
have like a trash taste rubik's cube
how many times in your life has have
like you gone to a party and you're like
oh my god it's a rubik's cube guys
i'm about to flex step back step back
here comes the asian kid
i think everyone who knows how to solve
rubik's cube yeah um
says they don't regret it no no
actually very
it's like weirdly an impressive skill to
have i i i promised in a video i was
gonna learn it it's not that hard i
actually learned it once as well because
i i learned i've completely forgotten it
so i remember like being that easy
though yeah it's not that
yeah because like i remember i was in a
hotel room um and i was staying in this
hotel and for some reason it was like
this you know it was like this chic
hotel they tried doing like different
things for their decorations and it just
had a rubik's cube that was unsolved in
this like really clean hotel right right
and my like ocd mine was just like
like how dare they it's hard perfect
like it's it's like they [ __ ]
designed this room to be like just
mildly infuriating just just
like like it was a perfectly clean room
it looked amazing but on the desk there
was just a rubik's cube on there it's
like those memes of like you should see
a picture it's like what's wrong with
this yeah yeah yeah right and like i i
could not sleep in this like hotel room
knowing that there was like i was just
like i was staring all night at this
rubik's cube that was just unsolved yeah
and so i just took a day where i just
googled how to solve a rubik's cube so i
could [ __ ] just
like i solve it before i went to bed
learn how to do it and it like i i never
really thought about how to solve a
rubik's cube before and i was like oh
it's actually pretty simple it's just an
algorithm basically yeah right it's just
it's just a bunch of like algorithms
when you're following a guide it's
pretty easy but the hard part is being
able to do it independently yeah yeah so
i never got to the point where it was
just like muscle memory you know i was
just like
it was just like you know it's a slow
process but anyone's able to solve a
rubik's cube i also remember like the
the reason why i actually like finally
learned how to solve it because i always
wanted to solve it since i was in high
school because again i got you know
called that kid but then you know
pandemic hit
everyone's stuck inside and it's like
you know i think everyone had that point
where it's like well i need to [ __ ]
do something right right i can only play
so many hours of animal crossing per day
right so something sourdough bread
exactly exactly so i was like all right
well let's like learn a bunch of useless
skills so i think i learned how to do
like four or five different useless
skills and rubik's cubes just happened
to be one of the
other ones uh the other one was um you
know you've probably seen it before you
know what kendama is
it's like this very old japanese toy
that it kind of looks like a hammer with
a ball oh that one yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i did that as a kid but i wasn't
very good at it
what is that like it's just like a it's
this like really ancient japanese toy uh
kind of like you know like spinning tops
yeah yeah it's like that what's the
challenge the challenge is you have to
so there's three different plates on
this like it looks like a hammer yeah
and there's like a concave like plate on
the bottom and there's two concave
plates on the side and there's like a
little spike on the top yeah yeah yeah
uh the the regular one yeah yeah the
regular one is like you kind of turn it
to the side and you have to
throw the ball up without actually
holding the ball and let it land in the
cup
yeah that's just like the simple skull
but there's like
a million different like tricks you can
do it's kind of like yo-yoing
right where it's like you can just like
regularly do a yo-yo and then there are
yo-yo tricks right which is just like on
another
level of difficulty and skill that's
cool and so like kendama is kind of the
same thing so like japan every year has
like these like kendama championships
where like you can actually get like
licenses
and like certificates to say that you're
a pro kendama like player if you do like
these certain tricks right that's cool
and one of the tricks
i could do like the regular cop right
because like that's [ __ ] easy like
anyone can do that honestly one of the
hardest ones is where you have to
get it so that the ball lands on the
spike right by doing this and that
sounds impossible uh there's a trick to
it but then i was like i'm going to
learn how to do that during this
pandemic yeah so i bought like a like a
proper like professional graded like
kendama because they have those there's
like the toy ones and there's no graded
yeah there's like a there's like a
kendama
seriously there's like a national
kendama committee in japan where they're
like they look at each kingdom and
they're like yeah you can use that in
those in competitions and it comes with
like a certificate to be like yeah this
is a certified kendall so did you learn
how to do it yeah learn how to do it
and now you've got to bring it into the
office i'm like curious now you can't
say that
there better be a video on screen right
now joey dude how have you never like
posted a video on twitter or something
because it's like the most niche thing
on the planet i would like to see it oh
yeah you just randomly like
in the next anime man or joey video yeah
just you just like have i'm just gonna
have like just casually do it just don't
explain yourself you just casually do it
i swear to god i swear to god every
comment is going to be about that one
thing right
i i was uh gifted a rubik's cube once as
a kid yeah um for christmas
by my parents oh okay but it was a harry
potter rubik's cube okay
so all the tiles were themed they were
all pictures of harry potter right i
loved harry potter of course i did
because i'm
and so i have this cube right and i'm
thinking wow this is just this is just
great yeah and i i turn it once so oh no
i'll put it back
i don't want to ruin it i don't know i
like the picture yeah what's the point
in the cube
that's me in basically everything
before so so
you know and then another day i go back
here and i turn it once turn it twice
i'm like no no
[Music]
no i
you know a few days later or whatever i
i love this cube
it's the most awful thing like it's so
hard to solve because the pictures are
so [ __ ] yeah yeah so i i start turning
in i turn it like four or five times and
i'm like okay i'm gonna start turning it
back
and then i turn it back i'm like one
okay
oh [ __ ] it's not back the way it was
yeah and then i'm like okay i think it's
like just one there's one thing out of
play i can fix this
i start trying things and i just keep
[ __ ] it up just gets worse and worse
and then i realized what a [ __ ] toy this
is i i'm like eight years old i cannot
solve this now i'm just [ __ ]
and now if i want to see the pictures of
harry potter i have to actually like
learn how to solve it yeah and i don't
know how no one's even began to explain
to me right algorithm i don't know that
i google i i get one hour a day to go
online i'm not using that i'm gonna go
watch yu-gi-oh gx episode 400 part one
of three yeah
i'm gonna do that no look at the rubik's
cube so i yeah yeah i i was just like
really disappointed i was really sad and
um i remember i found it a few years
later and i
i thought i'll i'll give it a shot i
just couldn't do it
that seems more difficult than a regular
one it wasn't yeah the pictures were all
like like
harry potter and his hogwarts so they're
all like you they're like brown did you
take like the stickers off yeah okay
that's what i did as a kid but then when
i did that it wasn't you know because it
was this is the factory yeah factory
production all the excuses were perfect
so when i started peeling them and [ __ ]
they were all like a little bit wonky
stickers are some of the most annoying
[ __ ] to like place yeah because you put
it and you're like i'm doing it
perfectly flat flat you put it on douche
i don't know how that happens every time
building a gun club you like yeah right
yeah exactly you're like [ __ ] it's
like that but oh
yeah i mean like i think
the only like useless skill i've learned
before was i i mean do you guys know how
to juggle
i i learned how to do the one-handed you
learn how to use the one-handed yeah but
like you know with two balls we kind of
like oh yeah yeah yeah i never i never
got to the point where it was with three
yeah i mean growing up in brighton beach
i remember like one day i just decided
to just learn how to juggle using
pebbles and stuff yeah and i think i can
still juggle i don't know i don't know i
don't know it's been a while we
actually the most
useful party trick dude you guys have
any party tricks that you that you like
can show off in a party or whatever not
that i don't know what i remember okay
i'm like [ __ ] susan boyle every party
i go to just everyone stops
actually like the most useless uh the
most useful party trick i know is just
being able to open a bottle with
anything yeah like i've done that a few
times because it's not just like it's
every time you do it if you wanna if you
wanna just know a trick that will take
you five minutes to learn but will be
useful in basically every party you go
to yeah just learn how to open a bottle
with a lighter or another box i feel
like us not showing these abilities is
like making this episode worse what's
going on
how often do you go to a party and you
see a rubik's cube there you're like
finally my voice
back boys my time to shine uh i can
click my wrists on command
can you
that doesn't sound healthy
oh
you got
you got like a eight-year-old wrist
is that the gamer wrist
yeah i only know like small little
things that will you know maybe impress
like
your five-year-old cousin yeah you know
when you're at a home like i can do like
the water droplet sound like that's the
only thing like oh yeah that's skype you
can do you can do the skype thing
perfectly the skype thing the skype
[Laughter]
that appeals to a very like tight knee
yeah like yeah yeah you had to be on the
internet in the mid 2000s to appreciate
that
the windows xp shut down noise
[Applause]
oh you've been able to um
do that thing where you like hold your
body up i don't know why i've always
been able to do that uh what do you mean
oh the one was like like through here
like that like when you're just like on
a surface and you cannot hold your whole
body oh you mean like what breakdancers
do kind of yeah yeah yeah i've always
been able to do that i don't know but
yeah you have to have like good core
strength for that don't you
i guess you've got slightly i guess like
you've got great core strength right i
don't know maybe i do i don't know
this like conversation just reminded me
that i like i went through like a phase
like you know every you're a kid and
sometimes you go through phases right so
i remember the first time i've ever saw
david blaine on on tv doing stream magic
and i'm just like i want to do that yeah
that looks incredible and i remember
like going through this phase where
i you know there was these packages this
was before you could just google or
youtube how to do magic tricks online so
i actually had to like pay like send off
i had to convince my parents to send off
money to this company that like
supposedly sent you magic tricks and uh
and like magic magic secrets and all
that sounds like a scam
i'm surprised like for the one time in
my life it wasn't a scam wow they
actually like sent me back like a vhs
though [ __ ] like played and i remember
you like learning how to do like a bunch
of these magic tricks yeah i'm just like
great i'm going to impress everyone
around me but like you there's never a
moment where you go to a party or you go
to a family gathering yeah and like you
don't want to be that guy who just
brings out a deck of cards
even though i learned how to use these
skills as a kid i never i never was able
to show them off so
it's i mean it's kind of like martial
arts in somewhere right
because uh you know talking to
i remember seeing this youtube video
about like why do people learn martial
arts because you basically you basically
spend years of your life you spend years
and years honing this one skill for like
these moments that will only last maybe
like a few minutes of your life right
unless you unless you go to tournaments
and stuff like that right because like
you like you're you're training yourself
for like that one fight you're going to
be in in like whatever moment that's
going to be right yeah but then you
spend years building up to that moment
and like what if what if you just [ __ ]
up in that moment right what if
what if all the training just just
leaves your body in that one moment the
dude's like nine foot
yeah yeah yeah right i didn't drive this
i'm like [ __ ] dude
wait are you getting are you oh [ __ ]
that's my weight class sorry yeah
i i feel like that's the good thing
though about like doing youtube is that
like for me i just use videos to do [ __ ]
that i otherwise wouldn't normally do so
like with like martial arts for instance
like i remember oh my god i don't even
remember how many years ago this was
this is like a four or five year old
video i uh i learned how to like
backflip
i was going to say if there's one skill
i want to learn how to do actually yeah
it's the back flip well that's just like
standing yes
standing back you're just standing back
i did a standing backflip once in a
video it was like
it was me and like was your power to
encourage you they're trying to get rid
of you it was no no it was i was in
japan already i was in japan and it was
me dogan and uh my friend alex you were
above the age of like 15 doing this yeah
this was like four years ago oh my god
that's like suicide yeah and we yeah
because we cosplayed as narrator
characters oh my god
that's the reason you learn how to
backflip because of naruto because it
was a narrative online sponsorship oh my
and i was like i was like well i need to
do something naruto related you know
what i'll learn ninja tricks and by
ninja tricks i mean just tricking and
learning how to backflow so how long did
it take you to learn how to backflip uh
like
like i think we were in that gym for
maybe like five six hours
but i learned how to do like other
tricking like tricks because like dogan
used to be like a [ __ ] like
professional trick trickster is that the
right word
sounds like a persona character
like parkour yeah yeah he used to do
like tricking and she's serious and then
he like hurt his uh knees i think really
badly and he like couldn't stop doing it
but he was like he taught me how to like
backflip and [ __ ] and uh i did it
successfully once yeah i haven't done it
since could you do you think you'd be
able to relearn and uh pull off another
backflip maybe because i think what took
me so long and i think what the the
level of entry is is that you just have
to get over your fear yeah yeah yeah
that's what like because i've seen
people trying to learn backflips yeah
i'm just like that looks really that
looks like a really interesting because
i snapped your neck just get over yeah
get over the fear
yeah because like it's not natural for
you to be like all right jump and also
pull your entire body back like this
yeah at the same time like your body's
just like no
i think that's cool but the one skill i
learned i also love this channel it's uh
mike boyd a boy yeah he does the he just
like
how long can it take me to learn next
thing oh i think i know that yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think there's one video and
i really want to learn how to do this
it's he has an umbrella and he's holding
the umbrella and
he this the trick is is that he throws
the umbrella in front of him it goes
like quite quite far away and then it
opens in mid-air and while he's walking
he catches the umbrella as it as he's
like so it fully opens yeah yeah yeah
yeah floats down he catches it yeah and
i want to learn how to do that there's
so many like little tricks that i want
to learn how to imagine you're on like
the japanese street and you're just like
right
it's like some anime [ __ ] i want to do
that with like a cap where like you
throw the cap and it lands perfectly on
your head but that's good enough because
you always need to like pull it down
right yeah with the umbrella it's like
immediate you're like walking you're
good to go no no readjustment you've got
the umbrella oh no you know what's a
truly useless skill i've always wanted
to learn is to draw a perfect hand so oh
yeah i've seen that yeah i've seen so
many videos and every time i see it i'm
just like not that is the most
satisfying thing in the world just like
freehand
yeah
yeah yeah the guy the guy does oh i do
that [ __ ]
yeah that's a cool party trick that is a
cool party trick everyone has a pencil
not everyone has a rubik's cube exactly
exactly i don't carry pencil on me all
the time well no if you're in someone's
house oh yeah yeah actually you're not
going to be in a house that doesn't have
a drawing equipment
of some kind have you ever been in a
house where they just don't have any
pens and pencils
i think it's my house already yeah
that's just connor's house right that's
my house
true millennial right here
what's what's pencils
actually i don't think i have a pencil
in my house
i have pens no there's no way you guys
live in japan there's more paperwork
than [ __ ] anything yeah
you just use pads yeah
that's what i mean like drawing things
yeah i guess like now that i'm thinking
touring equipment drawing drawings
what are you calling pets
unfortunately i don't draw
anything
when was the last time i drawed
something actually like the sad music
player i haven't drawn anything i
haven't seen the accident
i just have like zero skill in drawing
and i have done for my entire life i
think i don't know something we need to
do like a drawing competition now but
you said that somebody who also sucks at
drawing i believe it's like it's like
singing it's like i don't think you're
just like naturally good like
immediately i know you are actually i
think some people some people but i
think you you do have to practice though
yeah of course you have to practice but
i remember i think the last time i drew
something i can't remember what the uh
context was but i think i had to draw a
cat for something
oh it was the netflix shoot i remember
because it was for anime club in netflix
and i had to draw a cat on the
whiteboard or something and then joey
just said
joey just me like joey i was drawing
this cat and joey could not recognize
like that it was even an animal that i
was drawing on this white he drew like a
uma
i don't know what it was like it was
like it was not of this earth
like those uh like unidentified what is
it
like like the chupacabra
like that level it's like urban legend
[ __ ]
super camera what the [ __ ] the uma
something animal
this is the first time i've ever
unidentified a mysterious animal yeah
like like ufo this is the first [ __ ]
thing i've ever heard you know like
mothman or like super cabra like any of
those
umass unidentified mysterious animal i
just need any of those no
no no although when i was 10 i did
believe chupacabra but
why why would you believe in supercars
because you're 10 years old
you believe in you believe harry potter
is real when you're 10 years old like
mexican or something yeah it was mexican
or spanish i
mean means
means goat
drinker or something what is the
chupacabra
i killed it i killed it it was this like
viral video in like early 2000s i think
where like there was just it was mexico
or spain or somewhere some
spanish-speaking country where like just
some dudes went into a forest at night
because they heard some [ __ ] and then
there was this like
creature
that appeared on camera it was like that
goat person right yeah it was like it
was like eating a goat or it looked like
a demonic goat yeah and like i remember
like back then like it was a huge
sensation especially in japan it was a
massive sensation because for an early
2000s uh video it was like way too high
quality like it looked way too real like
you look you look at the you look at the
chupacabra videos now and you're like oh
that could almost like if you weren't
aware of it that could almost come off
as convincing yeah because it was like
too good and then people were like
shocked when they found out it was fake
and it's like oh who would have thought
there isn't a [ __ ] goat drinker demon
thing in the forest of mexico whatever
the [ __ ] it was yeah i think like the
only thing that i believed as a kid or i
wanted to believe i really wanted to
believe like the loch ness monster oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't know
because a kid you're just obsessed with
dinosaurs and you're like exactly edge
stories yeah yeah yeah like uh thinking
cool [ __ ] yeah exists out there but it
doesn't it's like everyone you know
everyone wanted to believe moby dick was
a real thing like bigfoot like a lot of
bigfoot a
for some reason but like it also like
makes me think what if what if one of
those things was real right what would
what would make you actually believe it
right because seeing it if i yeah if i
see it like
yeah if i see like a news article of
like scientists like properly talking
something incredible be like yeah this
is okay because because like i remember
because i think we have talked about
this before but like i mean it's been
proven by the government that ufos exist
yeah and like nobody freaked out over it
nobody really reacted to alex jones
yeah last year with the was it the black
folk but yeah like it's like
if it was
if i said to you oh by the way we found
an alien spaceship we know it's an alien
by the way you'd be freaking out but i
feel like oh we have no [ __ ] clue
what that thing was yeah it could have
been it could have been like a drawing
oh yeah or something
everyone like doesn't because you're
like oh well i'm sure there's an
explanation for it we just don't know
but if it's like by the way we literally
found the things from men in black and i
think everyone's gonna be like what the
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah i mean like because
i mean
it's weird right because you do look at
the videos i do look at the videos of
the ufo images and the ufo videos and
i'm just like that's freaky
and i do think ufos exist but do i think
it's aliens i don't know i don't i don't
know myself i don't i don't know how to
react to it i guess
no i was gonna say like there was a
there was a weird part of me that saw
those like government file you know
videos which are like you know legit and
right because like why would why would
an organization like that lie yeah but
it's like i saw and i was like why does
that look like just every other ufo
video i've ever seen i think that's the
problem with it right because there's so
many fakes nowadays that even when the
real thing is actually released you're
so desensitized with that you're just
like it's like the fake ones looked more
realistic yeah yeah right
it's just it i thought seeing ufos
real ufos would be more impressive and i
don't know why i thought that but i just
thought it would be more impressive and
it just wasn't you know i i mean i
assume that if uh an alien species finds
us uh we will probably be dead
wow they just wipe us out oh there's
like
think of it if an alien spaceship if
alien civilization had the opportunity
to or had the capability of finding
other planets and going around scouting
yeah they're more technologically
advanced than us yeah we're probably
[ __ ] yeah odds are they're not going
to want to be like hey
friends they're going to be like let's
take all your stuff yeah
you have minerals we need collect the
minerals
why would they give a [ __ ] they're not
going to give a [ __ ] they'll treat us
like cows yeah i mean i mean it's like
it's kind of i agree with you because i
think what if humanity had this had this
we would [ __ ] go everywhere we would
we
some other species planet you know
anyone who thinks that like we wouldn't
just blow off a planet if they if we
just thought they were a little
strange-looking yeah yeah that doesn't
have enough
especially if they have like natural
resources or something
i'm sure a lot of people would be like i
don't think we should do this but the
government of whatever the united
government of all whatever would be like
bye-bye
yeah
but they are rich in iron we must
destroy
exactly right yeah which uh speaking of
destroying planets and uh living through
the apocalypse i guess uh we we kind of
what a fantastic segway yeah what a
fantastic set we kind of lived to
something like that yesterday didn't we
yeah that was terrifying we had a very
big earthquake
yeah yeah yeah because you you you had a
very different experience
yeah we had a we had two big earthquakes
actually yesterday back to back uh i'm
sure the world news has covered it it's
probably old news by the time you're
watching this but uh well i mean it was
the biggest earthquake i have lived
through so far
i think it was bigger than one than the
one in l.a or at least it felt like it
was bigger than the one in la i think
tokyo was like mag four or five four
four four four point five yeah but i
think it was like magnitude 7.3 yeah
yeah yeah in fukushima um but yeah i
mean
i thought i'd experienced like
big earthquakes in japan before and this
one like even for people who have lived
here
lived in japan for longer than me said
that this was the biggest one that
they've experienced as well
and uh you know it's it's a lot of
people said it's the biggest one they've
experienced since the 2011 earthquake
yeah in uh in fukushima as well yeah
because i think i think it was because
it wasn't just one yeah it was like one
that was pretty big already that caused
another even bigger one yeah literally
two minutes later yeah so it just felt
like one continuously large earthquake
well how was it for you guys um am i
weird i like earthquakes you like
earthquakes i quite like it is that bad
like in what sense it feels like a fun
quick time event or something i don't
know
i don't know i don't know why but it
feels kind of fun is this weird yeah
i know this is weird yeah i don't know
it's a technically a natural disaster i
know i i know because it's like it
causes so many problems yeah like that's
like watching a bird
like i get it i guess well you don't say
that about like
this is the guy who gave us [ __ ] for
looking at fire like still canister and
here he is being like looking at an
earthquake
like
a disaster on like 10 times the
magnitude no more than not like
thousands of times the magnitude of an
exploding can and he's just like oh a
quick timer
the bayonetta music starts playing
i obviously protect my um whatever is
valuable in my house but also it's kind
of interesting seeing what what stays
and what falls over i'm quite quite
enjoyable
i understand before you take taking bets
i was out and i was kind of like hyped
to think like when i came back i was
like what fell over like nothing just
fell over and i was like you were
disappointed
okay
obviously if like my tv had fell over
i'd be like [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] but yeah you
know when it's mild ones like obviously
because it was it was a big earthquake
but it wasn't that big in tokyo yeah um
and i like i like those ones but
obviously if it was like eight yeah i'd
be like i'd be another thing entirely
yeah i do not like this one i do not
like this earthquake i mean like one
thing i
do not understand after having lived in
japan and experienced a bunch of
earthquakes now is when do they send out
the earth when did they start out the
earthquake alarms i do not get like i
swear to god it's when the epicenter is
close enough oh okay did you get one no
no i have never gotten one since i got
my new phone oh really yeah i've
definitely gotten a bunch but it's only
when the epicenter is close enough to
where you live where it sets it off
because it was in fukushima and miyagi
it was like too far away
right but the earthquake was big enough
to
the fact that we felt it yeah yeah
because i i hear that i hear the
earthquake alarm and i brace myself and
it's like the pitliest piddliest like
little earthquake i've ever felt like
out of nowhere like yesterday you get
you like the entire [ __ ] house starts
shaking i'm like why didn't i get alarm
for this i feel like this is like more
prevalent for like the alarm that i
should be bracing myself for
i do if you watch that youtube video
that's like noises that will give you
anxiety if you live in japan or
something yeah yeah and it's like all
the disaster noises yeah yeah you heard
the tsunami one yeah the tsunami was
terrifying it's horrible it's like it's
like like uh like the what's the tower
in pokemon called oh the the [ __ ]
pokemon tower like that that uh no the
one with the dead
uh yeah yeah pokemon tell pokemon too i
think no lavender tower
yeah it's like it's like that level of
creepy yeah the tsunami
this episode is sponsored by honey we
all shop online
right guys
guys
anyone and we've all seen that promo
code taunt us at the checkout but thanks
to honey manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past honey is a
free browser extension that scours the
entire internet for the best promo code
that you can use and applies it
automatically for you honey supports
over 30 000 stores online that ranges
from tech companies to gaming products
to fashion brands and even food here's
how it works just imagine you're
shopping at one of your favorite stores
online don't tell me don't tell me i'm
gonna guess
jesus christ that's what you're into and
then when you're at the checkout so the
honey button drops down and all we have
to do is click apply coupons wait a few
seconds there's honey searches for all
the available coupons that can find for
that site and then if it finds a working
coupon your watch as the prices drop
i've been getting ready to fly back to
england and recently honey saved me 10
on this new travel bag i got just for
that if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally free and installs
in a few seconds and by doing it you'll
be doing yourself a favor and helping us
out too so get honey for free today at
joinhoney.com trash taste that's join
honey.com trash taste thank you tony for
sponsoring this episode back to the
video
oh that's it i [ __ ] hate that it's
horrible yeah that one that one's
horrible dude that one
it sounds like when you get an item in
an rpg it sounds like i just opened a
box in zelda or something
i think it's creepy because like it's
slightly dissonant yeah yeah and it it
feels that
it feels like you're in a room that is
like collapsing
oh yeah it's designed to do that and
it's like you're dying it's it's like
it's like you're in a game and you just
like triggered a bad event no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no i
know
have you ever heard like those music
remixes where they take a happy song and
they remix it in like a minor key that's
exactly what it sounds like you're
talking about like wrecking ball and
gmail yeah yeah yeah
joey guess what yeah
yeah yeah my the one that always gives
me [ __ ] anxiety is the the earthquake
alarms yeah
but that one feels dangerous yeah yeah
the tsunami one is creepy because it
doesn't feel like it's it's like oh my
god this is like a world-ending event
yeah this is like it just sounds like a
minor discomfort yeah
it's like it's like the mole's closing
yeah i mean like for my for the
earthquake yesterday for me so it was
actually big enough that it knocked out
the power in uh in my section of tokyo
um
sorry dogs yourself well
it was like the power got outed in a
bunch of i mean i think i think the news
said it was like two million homes were
out of power yeah
i might have lost power but i was i was
out so you definitely would have known
if you lost yeah i wasn't there oh okay
you want it home okay
i could have gone out yeah mine was fine
yeah i mean like i actually didn't even
feel the first one i don't know like
sometimes sometimes people sometimes
people are just like oh there was an
earthquake and i'm like i didn't feel it
was there really an earthquake or did
you just stand up too fast
you know because i that happens to me
sometimes yeah where i think it's an
earthquake happening but it's really
just it's just tripping balls yeah yeah
i just feel like a little lightheaded
are you watching something in dolby
atmos i genuinely i genuinely think
there's always an earthquake happening
i'm watching daily albums
well like the thx starts it's like
yeah dude like the floor shakes
like oh [ __ ] are we
good yeah so i was actually in my office
on the bottom on the ground floor
because i live in the house and uh
sydney was chilling on the bed um on the
third floor of our house and i just hear
i i just hear sydney going gone gone
gone and uh i'm just like i'm i didn't
know it was an earthquake going on so i
was just like taking my time with her
like let me let me let me let me let me
finish this uh piece of work and i'll
just like casually stroll upstairs and
uh i see sydney like just looking
shell-shocked because uh cindy's like
really sensitive to like earthquakes and
like natural disaster kind of thing so
she's just like
did you did you feel that did you feel
that and i was like what wha wha what's
going on sydney that was an earthquake
that was an earthquake and i was like
was there
are you sure sydney are you sure like
because i didn't feel i didn't feel it
at all right i didn't feel this at all
and so i you know i was i was like about
to check my phone to see if you know
every anyone else had posted about it or
anything like that and then just as i go
out
just as i got out my phone it's like the
second the second quake hit the second
quarter the bigger one the bigger one
and it's like you know this one this one
it didn't like immediately start off
strong for me it like shook a little bit
it shook a little bit and so it started
shaking i was like oh that's an
earthquake and sydney was like huh yeah
you feel it now the son of a [ __ ] you
feel it now you feel it [ __ ] now and
then as she finished that
our lights just like turn off right
and there was just an immediate 180 from
oh
no no no come on
[Music]
it was actually like pretty surreal for
me
because uh
it was the first time i mean in thailand
we're like [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] used to
power outages we have like plenty of
lights and everything like that um in
here it was just so surreal seeing just
my entire block basically my entire town
just like in complete darkness i think i
posted a video of me just like walking
around outside my house i have never
seen
my street
almost in
complete darkness
this
is freaky as hell which uh because it
was the first time i'd just seen any
side of tokyo just completely dark yeah
emergency lights on it was like
it was kind of kind of surreal right
like apocalyptic yeah kind of kind of
apocalyptic right um so like because i
was i was what because i thought why not
just take a walk just to see just to see
what the city is take it in yeah just
just to see what the city is like when
we're going through a disaster like this
um
and i think the first time it hit me of
just how surreal this was was i walk out
and you know tokyo was dark but the
point it actually hit me was when i
walked to my main road and i could see
the lawsons had its lights out and i'm
just like holy [ __ ] even the combination
this is the first time i've ever seen
the [ __ ] combination out and like the
the employees are in there just like
[ __ ] they couldn't even open the door
because like the power like the
automatic door wasn't open i was like oh
this is this is real
i don't know why it was the combini just
because like like i i thought no matter
what like a comet could be crashing and
like lawson's would still be like serbia
yeah because like like even when japan
has like the worst typhoon in like the
past 10 years which i think it did like
last year the year before two years ago
the only thing that was open the loss
the combination the combinies are all
over thick and thin yeah so that was
that was the first time yeah that was
that was the first time it was surreal
for me because it was also just seeing
which parts of the grid were still
supported
so actually like because i had to walk
around so like it was some traffic
lights were working and some weren't so
that that was that was that was weird
traffic lights weren't working yeah some
of the traffic lights weren't working
right but i think they must have
prioritized the more busier
intersections right because
uh all like some of the all the big
intersections were working but some of
the smaller ones
weren't working i always thought that
the
uh
road lights and stuff were on a separate
thing entirely from the normal power
they might have like a backup system
yeah yeah
the last thing you want is um no no
traffic no traffic lights yeah and
though there was actually a traffic
accident like near where that's not
rising at all yeah i was i think might
have been because of that but like the
only thing that was actually lit was
um was the train stations actually the
train stations had everything working
and the elevators were still working and
everything even though everything else
was like pitch black that wasn't the
only thing that was lit gone i was i was
having a great time
in akihabara
i was having a whale of a time i was in
the basement right then some anime song
ball right in there there's a bunch of
japanese men
singing uh macross songs right with a
bunch of
very young looking girls
okay so we went in there and we were
just having a good time
you're like man
i'm [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] lighting this
place on fire man yeah i'm singing now
singing colors
everyone clapped i thought like the base
of your voice was just like so strong
that he was shaking the entire jojo as
well so
yeah i mean everyone in that bar was
like oh they got dolby atmos here
holy [ __ ]
it was so funny i would it would it
would have came uh the i was with the
guys that did the wrestling video with
uh he was like oh there's an earthquake
just now i was like i didn't know yeah
and then 10 seconds later the second one
that was bigger started like shaking and
we were all like yeah
uh and then yeah but we were in the
basement it was shaking but it wasn't
like that bad like that's why initially
i was quite shocked when i was getting
texts a bunch of text people being like
yeah uh sorry that scared me i was like
ghost ghost earthquake earthquake
um that's why i was quite shocked when i
was getting so many texts and people
being like
oh my god are you okay are you okay
well weirdly enough you don't feel it
when you're on the ground you feel it
when you're really up high right yeah i
mean you feel it more at least yeah you
feel the way more when you're up high
yeah it was all right it was good
because a lot do you get a lot of people
who don't live in japan who don't you
aren't used to earthquakes messaging you
people oh yeah yeah of course oh my gosh
are you okay after after after the round
of like people living in japan tweets
that i saw i started to get like 17
messages from people all over the world
because once it hit the mainstream like
you know international news yeah it's
weird because it's like i get it because
like how could you know the severity of
it but i think if i'm tweeting about it
it's probably it's probably how it means
i'm okay
yeah i mean like i think it's worse for
like something like chris right because
he was living right next to it like i
can't imagine how strong the earthquake
was for him hit really hard yeah yeah
exactly because i've never been in an
earthquake where a lot of stuff has
literally just like gone on the floor
and started smashing because i think i i
don't know why i'm oddly calm during an
earthquake and i remember like i like it
you see what i
i remember like because i remember
seeing aki's video
that she took
and i related to joey so of course like
because of course me and joey sharing
the same brainstorm but i remember
relating to joey so hard just seeing aki
just like freaking out going to the bed
and joey just sitting with like stone
cold face
on the couch which is just like
experiencing the world ending around him
and joey's just
this is fine
it was literally just like this is fine
face
cool
that's two earthquakes
there's a level six just yeah that was a
little six fukushima
i don't want that the one that got me
down online was uh like afterwards it
started to like really shake right yeah
so aki ran to the other side of the
house like to the bed because like uh we
always go to the bedroom because there's
nothing in our bedroom other than our
bed right so there's like we don't have
any worry about things like falling on
us and stuff like that yeah so we go to
the bed
she's like calling out to me i'm like
why the [ __ ] you calling messi you're
the one that left me behind
she like bolts and bolts into the bench
just like joey where are you and i'm
like what do you mean
you left me in the living room
and so there's just this footage of me
just like casually strolling in with my
hand on my head being like oh two
earthquakes
oh [ __ ] sick
and people like just joey just like like
just as a chad just like walking in like
dad pose like hand on his head just like
i think someone said like why does he
look like a dad that's like waiting for
like an argument
but to be fair in my defense
i i was surprised because i looked way
calmer in that video than i actually was
because i think in those kinds of
situations like this the one that
happened yesterday
oh you did a video
and yeah i think i was i i was surprised
because i was like oh i look way calmer
than i actually was because in my inside
i was like oh [ __ ] this is like really
long also i was worried about my grandma
because she lives up north right so i
was like trying to text her and stuff
but out of context it just looks like me
just [ __ ] standing there just like
waiting for this earthquake to end like
come on
end or end already [ __ ] i didn't want to
go in one of those like uh i know they
had it in like cashews castle yeah they
had the challenge where you had to like
sit in like the japanese tatami room
yeah on one of those earthquake uh
simulation things oh yeah and they have
to like try and sit on the platform
without falling over while it's like
magnitude 9.
i really want to go i've i've been on
one of those oh dude yeah that sounds
funny yeah i did a video at like the
like emergency center oh yeah yeah in
japan and like you got where you get to
experience like a house fire and like an
earthquake and stuff like that and they
have one of those things and i tried it
on magnitude 9 which is the same as the
2011 earthquake right dude it's crazy
like right what was it feel like it just
it just feels like four guys are just
surrounding you just doing this like
like you can't even like i was sitting
down like legs crossed i was sitting
down and like after the first shake like
i was
like holy [ __ ] like you cannot even
like lie down straight like it's so
[ __ ] intense
and so it really like went to sleep like
you know when you hear magnitude 9 right
you're like oh [ __ ] that seems really
big but i think like actually
experiencing magnitude 9 is
isn't it exponential yeah i think they
just like whoever whoever designed the
richter scale really
really like [ __ ] up by making it a
logarith uh logarithmic scale because
it's not like it's not uh linear right
so it's like it's logarithmic no do you
mean exponential
i think that's what
it's the inverse of exponential is it so
logarithmic means that it goes like this
and then exponential means it goes like
this okay i might be okay
i think so i just want to say
logarithmic one of them sounds
the gains that you see are initial and
then it starts flattening out whereas
exponential is the opposite
oh it is logarithmic thank you okay but
you were trying to explain the
exponential i'm smart
you said the right word but you were
saying the wrong thing
what i'm saying is we're professionals
exponential is kind of
and also logarithmic kind of it's the
inverse of a logarithm
yeah i don't know about that i don't
know i don't know because like it's the
opposite
i don't know man
by the way it's like okay it's not
linear it's not linear it's it's inner
scale yes yes actually logarithmic
functions are the inverses of
exponential functions
so how is this all right so richter
scale is logarithmic richter scale is
logarithmic so that means that it would
the the after like four or five the
difference isn't much
that can't be right
hence the word exponential it goes
exponentially higher this kind of just
what this kind of just proves my points
the original point i was trying to make
was that they you they put it in a scale
that is not comprehensible by the normal
human person which we are which we are
literally proving
right now you know like but like you
hear about you hear like an eight or
nine on the richter scale and you're
just like oh that's just one up from a
seven and i've seen people survive
sevens
your mind can't comprehend the the
effects like the the tangible effects of
just how much larger that is you know
yeah yeah and that's that's why that's
why i think they [ __ ] up because if
you hear like oh it was
on a scale of like a thousand on like
this earthquake scale you're like that's
that's a big number compared to compared
to a hundred which is which is what
which is what we're technically talking
about when we're talking going up from
magnitude seven to a magnitude eight yes
yes and i think
like i i don't know why we went with a
logarithmic logarithmic scale for like
disasters when the normal person can't
comprehend that amount of difference
with just one number you know sure true
yeah i mean can't even comprehend what
logarithmic and exponential are so how
does he get a couple
so that means that there wouldn't be
much difference between eight and nine
but there is
well
the scale says that there isn't jay ah
is that right there's not much of a
difference between eight and nine
i don't know
a mannerism i invented the richter scale
i'm having an end user technically it's
supposed to indicate an intensity ten
times yeah the previous yeah that's
that's what it's also described as a
logarithmic scale so i don't know
yeah that's what i thought
logarithmic [ __ ] line i know i know
what a logarithmic line is but it
doesn't make sense because i've learned
that the richter scale is the higher the
number the bigger the difference in
scale yeah i i i thought it was like 10
times the previous number yeah right no
because what i mean i guess it could be
but also because it goes like this right
right so let's say this was like eight
if it was eight like at the peak or
something yeah it's not going to get
much better at nine i've also increased
depends on the function you put into it
yeah that's what i thought because the
logarithmic logarithmic scale doesn't
necessarily have to look like that it's
just as a scale that's not linear yes
it's not just a non-linear scale it's uh
yeah so that's that is a logarithmic
logarithm and that is also what i
understand to be exponential as well
that's what i thought it's an
exponential logarithmic scale that's
what i thought at least it's an
exponential logarithmic yeah yeah
because it keeps going up okay yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
so so so either way either way my
original point wasn't wasn't the fact
that exponentials are the same as
logarithmic that wasn't what i was
trying to explain i was trying to
explain that
i'm right
either way i was trying to say that this
[ __ ] is too confusing for the normal
person to comprehend which maybe we
aren't more we aren't the normal person
maybe we're just dumber than a normal
speaker for yourself maybe we'll just
dump bottom line you bottom line you
could say that the earthquake yesterday
was magnitude seven yeah but if you've
never been in an earthquake of that
magnitude you're not going to [ __ ]
know what that feels like right yeah
like you guys have never been in a
magnitude seven
yesterday was a magnitude like four max
in tokyo yeah and like that's fun zone
for me yeah
i think
six sounds scary six i wonder what how
big the one in la was that we
experienced i want to say that was
probably around the same like maybe like
a magnitude four yeah yeah it wasn't it
was it felt around well it depends like
where we were wasn't it didn't feel that
bad yeah but i can't imagine what it is
like even if it goes like if if it's
like ten times more powerful than that i
mean i've been in a six as the is the
best
america is the most volcanoes in the
world
does it
not active but total volcanoes oh really
no whereabouts just hawaii the whole
thing well i think hawaii is a lot yeah
of active ones right but in general
america's a lot more than japan
yeah more volcanoes than japan wow i
thought japan had the most no maybe
japan is the most active ones no that's
indonesia
yeah i think that is indonesia japan
can't be number one america also has
like a massive landmass yeah so i'm not
like surprised about it because the most
volcanoes that like aren't active
yeah they're like don't do anything yeah
yeah then they have like yellowstone
which is like a ticking time bomb for
extinction you know
i mean i mean it kind of is right if
yellowstone ever explodes then uh
humanity [ __ ] uh yeah well same with
male fuji right yeah i think as well
there's
if any volcanoes erupt in the art
antarctic i think there's i think
there's some volcanoes underneath the
ice yeah yeah yeah yeah and if they
explode then
it's just gone yeah well the world's
gone
that water's got to go somewhere
is really good at keeping that [ __ ] in
yeah which uh which like because
yesterday made me wonder like it made me
appreciate
just how prepared are you for a disaster
right because it's just music huh
vsauce music right we were in the
penultimate episode of earth i think
right now you think we're the you this
is like penultimate episode kind of five
wait hold on
we got a war going on we've got global
warming with the pandemic the
earth's shaking trying to rip itself
apart right we're in the world the mines
were off by a few years you know you
know you know when you have like the
like when it's like the disaster movie
and you have the beginning the acts one
where you have all of the indicators
that the world is ending
but nobody pays attention to it i
believe like 2020 has like literally
been that indicator irl
take a shot of the seismograph go crazy
get that on film
yeah cause like i remember like when the
lights went out uh and i was walking
around i was like okay if this was like
that's the title of the movie when the
lights went out when the lights went out
when we lost power i was just like i
made me think what if this was like
actually just you know an a super super
serious earthquake and like the power
would be out for
a time when i didn't know when they
would be back on and you would be fine
which is just like i kind of realized
how much foreshadowing of
i'm gonna call it foreshadowing right
because it's basically a chekhov's gun
at this point
of items i have collected thanks to
trash taste
that would help me through a disaster
right so the first thing i realized is i
like our house was the only house in our
streets with any lights on and that's
because i had my [ __ ] brick of a
power bank that i had accidentally
bought for the camping episode which uh
if you need a flat if you need a
flashback uh you can here's a here's
here's a thumbnail of the clip of me
talking about the brick that i bought by
accident for the camping episode but it
wasn't by accident but it was i didn't
know it wasn't by accident like the
script he foresaw what was gonna happen
the scriptwriters for trash taste is
just like on another level like like
they they foreshadowed this like two
seasons
is writing the gold cards live
so like i i remember the lights being
off and me thinking [ __ ] i do not have
any torches or any sources of power
wait a minute
and i remember i thought i'd never ever
actually be able to use it for the use
that it was intended for and luckily i
had just charged it like a week before
so like we just plugged we could
literally just plug in our lamps and we
just lit up like our bedroom like it was
normally in your entire house yeah yeah
we could charge our phones and
everything but like beyond that i was
also thinking what if like what if this
was a natural apocalypse and we needed
to
well we needed to survive for you know a
bit longer and i remember uh do we have
any like do we have like a good supply
of water or like supplies to emergency
rations to get us through the day and i
was like wait a minute
i just bought an entire like me and
cindy both have an entire fridge
full of green tea that we bought as like
an aesthetic thing for our streams right
so if you've seen any of my streams or
any of my uh any of my uh on-camera
shorts there's there's a mini fridge
that i have and that's just full of
green tea that could last me
for a decent amount of time and
beyond that i also have a backup just
like an entire crate full of green tea
so i can like constantly refill this up
so unknowingly just from trying to make
something look aesthetic in my
background i'm able to like just survive
so much though yeah
i'm able to survive and not only that
i'm just like do we have any food to be
able to like last us i'm like
sydney's got like 10 months worth of
boxes just lying about
so it's like thanks to boxing we also
have emergency rations as well
so i've got like an emergency kit yeah
so do i got like
uh quite a lot of water you got quite a
lot of water i've got that i've got like
that bottle of water that lasts like
four years or whatever it is
what yeah there's like emergency water
that japan makes where it's like water
that supposedly lasts emergency
what do you mean it would last four or
five years it's like been specifically
made so that it doesn't go off
yeah water can go off what i'm still
gonna drink that [ __ ]
well yeah water can get stagnant
bacteria and stuff
like special like it's like acoustic
it's called well i've got like
i don't know like 10 liters of water or
something can bottled water go off yeah
yeah
after a while like after like a year i
mean you could still drink it you can
still drink it
some other [ __ ] wait so you actually
have an emergency kit yeah when did you
buy it
there's something on amazon yeah
one for a video yeah i don't know if i
don't use it i'll just uh whatever i you
know i looked into i was like oh should
i get one of those solar panel
battery charging things turns out
they're like a lot of [ __ ] and
they're like barely work yeah yeah yeah
i was like oh and this one was like just
get a wind-up torch it's like way better
just get the [ __ ] brick [ __ ]
battery pack they cost yeah but like you
got to keep that thing fully charged
yeah if it's in my cupboard for like 12
months it might have half the charge
yeah half the charge could probably
still last you like six months yeah i'm
actually probably gonna get like an
emergency pack now because i never
really thought about it before
before yesterday it
did humble me a bit just you know even
though even though just you know even
though you're fully prepared
even though i am i am prepared in many
ways thanks to thanks to trash taste and
the trash taste lore and uh just being a
content creator you know
i didn't i didn't i didn't purposely
prepare for it but uh
sorry
but uh yeah i mean i just have a lot of
things lying in my house that is useful
for your survival uh watch those videos
that are like what to do if there's a
nuke oh yeah you're like all right
yeah you mean like the you mean like the
lie down with your mouth open
do you know that one what's that one
hold on tell me this apparently i saw a
video i don't know how true it is but
apparently it's like it's like what what
to do if a nuke uh explodes like not not
close enough where it can like
immediately kill you but it's like if
like the shock wave could like possibly
kill you and apparently i don't know if
this is true so please take this with a
grain of salt yeah but it's like you
have to supposedly lie down with your
like head facing
away from the blast and you have to have
your mouth open because if your mouth is
closed then the shock wave can puncture
your lungs
but if the mouth is open then it lets
the air escape from your mouth
supposedly that's like a trick that
people have just figured out again
math breathers rejoice we were talking
about breathers
we were talking about useless skills
right i know that little useless
that is or it could come very useful
that is a piece of knowledge you see in
one life hack on a youtube show and then
you immediately forget about it
actually i wouldn't forget that that's
very rare yeah i remember and again i
don't know how true this is i've never
personally experienced anything like
that so i haven't tested it myself so if
i see a nuke going off i lie down on the
ground so say if it's coming out from
that window over there you would face
that one
calculations oh [ __ ]
yeah and yeah you'd like kind of have
your head down and you'd open your mouth
so that the shock wave can go through
your body
rather than it because if it's closed
then it gets closed off and it's still
going along right oh it's still going to
hurt but it won't kill you is the thing
i feel like if a nuke's going off your
life's pretty [ __ ] anywhere well i
mean if you're close
[Music]
open your mouth guys
trust me like the next indiana jones he
does like he just [ __ ] the fridge and
he just just turns around with his mouth
he's like in the fridge and he's like oh
[ __ ]
i forgot
that only works the only reason the the
fridge technically worked right because
it's a lead fridge right they don't have
lead fridges no they're not so it's i
can imagine much people jumping in their
fridges and it's like it's not going to
do anything you just put yourself in a
coffin yeah basically you just made it
he's going to cook yourself alive yeah
so i um
it was like uh they were saying so
you're 15 minutes when the nuke goes off
if you're not in the immediate danger
zone yeah yeah you're 15 minutes before
like the fallout reaches the ground
level yeah um so you need to get getting
daughters in 15 minutes and not leave
but you still might be dead from the
radiation yeah yeah of course but
obviously if you get any fallout on you
i think you die
yeah probably radiation sickness sounds
horrible
yeah yeah really really
chernobyl man that that that uh hbo
series is like rough well it wasn't just
that i think the one thing that really
horrified me was hearing about that
japanese guy who was like i i think he
was like the most radioactive person who
ever lived oh right yeah
he was working for i believe a nuclear
power plant or something like that so um
for what i don't know the full story but
for whatever reason uh during a routine
maintenance thing with when he was
handling radioactive material um they
made a mistake uh due to like time
constraints and you know trying to get
this project done faster than usual so
they were pouring way more radiation
material into this tank than um
than was ever allowed by regulations
right
um and you know obviously a chain
reaction happened something went wrong
and this guy who was literally standing
right next to the tank
um right next to the tank pouring in
this radioactive material he got hit by
the full blast of this chem uh
chemical reaction that was happening
right so he it's he was literally the
most radioactive person who has ever
been documented in history right yeah
and um and it's like a [ __ ] horrific
story of like he actually survived it
initially right he survived initially
and he they they went to hospital and he
on the first day he looked so well
that the nurses were like ready to
discharge him the next day
that is until they like looked looked at
his like dna and his dna had been
obliterated like jesus like [ __ ]
obliterated right and i don't think like
anyone at that point realized the
gravity aside from like doctors of
course realized the gravity of just like
what was in store for this guy because
like he got to the point where because
his cells could not make new cells right
um so he got to the point where the
doctors were trying to save him because
his family and himself wanted you know
to try everything they could but i feel
like it would have been less painful
just just to just let him pass away yeah
yeah because like it got to this point
where his body just started
deteriorating
um his skin would fall off
and would start bleeding and passing and
he'd like they could do nothing but just
bandage him up because there's there was
no way
for like for his uh for his body to make
new cells and he's he basically just
deteriorated to death and it's like
you hear about the accounts of this and
it sounds like [ __ ] that's probably
the worst way it was
one of the worst ways i was thinking of
a different story uh of like uh the guy
who was like living in hiroshima during
world war ii and then when the bomb
dropped right and he survived that one
yeah i mean he escaped with his family
out of hiroshima
to nagasaki
and then the second bomb dropped and he
survived that one as well
i thought i thought you were talking
about that story oh no no yeah i think i
think he must have been pretty [ __ ]
radioactive after that apparently i
don't know if this is true but i
remember hearing that there's more it
was not just him there's a few other
people as well but they they reckon that
uh maybe a hundred or so people have the
same idea yeah yeah yeah but they just
don't know who they are right yeah um
but i mean that is
crazy yeah really crazy yeah yeah
definitely yeah
just like just like thinking of thinking
about it so there's a youtuber i can't
remember his name he talks about a lot
of these um uh radiation uh stories and
and uh mistakes and stuff i can't bring
his name he's um he does the science
videos as well [ __ ] his name they're
really really good right and uh is there
some other horrible stories about like
people doing experiments that went wrong
there was that other story i think i
know which you should be talking about
there was he did he got the amazing hair
yeah did he make that video on the guy
who like stuck his head in the hadron
collider
yeah so yeah yeah and he got like shot
it wasn't collider but it was i think a
similar
thing yeah he got shot by an atom yeah
in the head
and like penetrated his brain and he
survived it
but like but yeah and then there was
some some like mix-up where they thought
he was alive he's like amazing hair he's
got like a lion's mouth
not the guy who got shot the guy makes
the youtube videos
like this is this is kyle kyle hill yeah
is this some new kind of like therapy to
give you like amazing hair just get you
stopped
shut up are you experiencing hair loss
boom
shot you've definitely seen this
thumbnail it's called the demon core you
seen this one oh yeah yeah yeah that was
a good video yeah yeah that was horrible
story though so yeah people [ __ ]
around with this thing and then it goes
wrong and then like all of a sudden
it was just like nuclear act nuclear
active cause it's always new clearly
yeah
it was i can't remember exactly what it
was watch the video it's really good and
there's just time at the story and
there's really really strange sometimes
you just think like why just leave it
just don't just what happened with the
guy who got shot by a datum he survived
he was he survived but then he
unsurprisingly developed these like
really weird uh like brain traumas and
uh like he i think he survived he
definitely yeah he survived he survived
for a while i believe but like he lost
all of his hair and then he uh yeah he
just had all these like weird brain
complications that the doctors were like
i don't know what the [ __ ] to do with
this yeah he's currently 79 years old
and living
79 years old and living okay
what a what a [ __ ] badass title got
shot by an atom yeah so so we know that
100 of the time as we know you when you
put a head in uh and a hadron collider
you survive yeah
i'll [ __ ] stick my head in there like
tomorrow jump in the hadron collider
real quick there's been other cases as
well people get the um
uh
what's the thing that powers x-rays uh i
think there's like a ah
something i was one one k i don't know
if it was extra exactly there's a
medical device yeah and some people
broke into an abandoned hospital right
like stole this thing right and they
just thought it was some kind of like
cool glowing thing yeah yeah turns out
that cool glowing thing was like
radioactive like uranium or something um
yeah i could be mixing up two stories
together here it's on his channel as
well and really weird and now they're
the teenage mutant ninja turtles well i
think the whole
i can might be a different story
actually but yeah like the whole village
they were like everyone come check out
the glowing stone oh no no no joke and
people were all touching it and playing
with it
and like like a whole like like uh
family and a few other people died
because they were just touching and
playing with the stone [ __ ] it out let
me pee all right don't ever touch
glowing stones kids
if it's glowing that's probably a bad
sign that a chemical reaction is
happening there that shouldn't that you
shouldn't be holding right because glow
sticks cursed glow sticks are making us
think that there's things that glow are
so cool god damn it this video is
sponsored by foxu boxu here is a monthly
snack box subscription service that
delivers premium japanese snacks and tea
pairings straight from japan to your
door every single bee you beautiful
boxer here has their very own gourmet
theme that changed every single month
the first box you that you will receive
is called the seasons of japan curated
by their snack experts to bring you a
taste of japan's four seasons and taste
what a year of boxing would be like
following the seasons of japan you will
receive a new beautiful snack box just
like this one themed every single month
and this theme is tanjorbi which if you
don't know in japanese just means
birthday and there is snacks in this
book from every single part of japan
i've had these before which are
delicious and a bunch of these i've had
before but some of these i've never seen
before and of course there's a tea
pairing with it so if you want to try
some of the authentic japanese snacks in
here and support me and the boys you can
do so right now just smash that link in
the description down below and when
you're there use coupon code trash taste
15 to get 15 off your first boxu order
do you guys reckon you could survive the
zombie apocalypse no
although maybe they got ubereats still
going if not
i don't know i don't know it depends
where you are right like if you're in an
area that's just like you're the only
one remaining ever like there's just
zombies [ __ ] clawing at your
apartment or whatever then it's just
like yeah just at that point i'm just
like okay well this the world's [ __ ]
anyway you know whatever i mean i don't
i don't know i feel like a zombie
apocalypse wouldn't be that hard to
survive that's what i'm saying like
that's that's my biggest like unless it
depends on the type of zombie right
because if you're talking about like the
traditional really slow [ __ ] zombie
that [ __ ] walks
like how did this become an apocalypse
in the first place how are people this
incompetent that this became an actual
apocalypse it's because in all those
movies they're just like no
don't come here while they're standing
still all right like no
if it's 28 days later all right now now
now i get how can
yeah if we're like talking like zombies
then it's like yeah i'm [ __ ] but i
feel like you know how like some of the
movies they make they manage to make
like villages that are like really tall
walls and
stuff i feel like that's that would be
if i've learned anything from dead
rising it's just just stay them all
yeah yeah hit them with a with a phone
phone back
yeah combine it with a chair hit him
with a bench put the machine guns on the
wheelchair yeah and drive the wheelchair
and i feel like you know i feel like if
a zombie apocalypse ever did happen
that's the one place where you know
being in america would be a massive
[ __ ] advantage because you think
about how easy it is to gain access to
weapons here in japan until the zombies
learn about those and they're like we
could use
oh i thought you were gonna be like
because you can just go like north
dakota and there's no one there
oh that true that's that's that escape
to wyoming
oh you're an idolater zombies actually
don't want to go there yeah
they'll go to the border
i mean that's that's the one place where
if you have a gun it would be like very
very useful like yeah but i mean you're
assuming guns will stop zombies exactly
that's true that is true because like
games have led us to believe that it's
like you want to kill a zombie just get
good at head shots but it's like
realistically will it actually kill how
much ammo can you really get a hold of
you know resident evil got one thing
right it'd be [ __ ] annoying to be
like conserving your ammo
i wouldn't be like a zombie could be
right in front of me and i'd be like
searching for like an axe or something
be like i don't shoot a zombie i don't
know i don't even shoot a zombie you
know maybe i'll need this ammo for like
the boss battle whatever that guitar
collection boys
are winning that's for sure i would do
anything i could even if i had a gun to
not use a gun just in case i'm gonna go
back to the safe room
apocalypse probably
honestly the best thing you could
probably have is just having a medieval
set of armor and whacking yeah like like
a sword how the [ __ ] are they gonna bite
you yeah you're wearing a full like
chain mail and you've got a big ass long
sword
yeah those chats on youtube the ones
you're talking about the
correct sword techniques they're they're
gonna be the real winners yeah yeah
that's what i've always like struggled
to to figure out right like the the
video game logic of yeah just shoot him
in the head and i'll stop them and i'm
like
but they're dead already
why would why why would they die like a
normal human being
i mean i don't know yeah it depends how
the zombies function yeah
yeah we're talking about fake uh i mean
fake science now it could you know it
could be it could be any sort of reason
or anything like if you just like you
know if you like if you have a [ __ ]
katana or something and you just like
you know chop their body into bits then
they can't do anything right even if
they're still alive you're going to chop
someone's body in a video you know how
long that's going to take okay
for one zombies you're going to be naked
zombie apocalypse i'm going to take them
out one at a time you know joe's gonna
let me just sit down and have a breather
when he's done hold on hold on
joey thinks that katana works like it
does an anime we just like does like the
[ __ ] sword thing and like the zombies
you know there's zombies in 100 pieces
that's true
all right you know what guns gonna be
yeah flamestar is pretty good right
flamethrower yeah
i mean is a flamethrower an actual good
weapon or is it just like an aesthetic
weapon it's a very good weapon um it's a
waste of money but i mean if you if you
hit someone with it they died but
wouldn't wouldn't i i know that but yeah
but one of the fuel for a flamethrower
would be more scarce than boats yeah
surely there's more effective weapons
and like it looks cool and it's affected
but surely there's more efficient
weapons i should say than that
it's like
but like if you hit someone i think with
it i think they just because like the
ones that like i think like elon musk
style for example yeah that's basically
just like a hairspray with a lighter
yeah yeah i think the original ones in
like world war ii were like they would
actually shoot out oil on fire yeah
because you could see the streams of
liquid yeah so they would land in here
and obviously if you get hit with that
that's just gonna like burn of course
but like what i'm trying to say is you
you know you you you have two guys one
person has a flamethrower one person has
a gun i think the person with the gun is
going to win come out of that battle
right yeah but you're not fighting
you're finding a zombie that's true
that's true okay okay i feel like
your goal is to make it so the zombie
can't move what a weird topic
i feel like
your goal
what if the zombie doesn't feel the the
heat but what if you burn off like his
legs
but you could just chop off his legs as
well
are you gonna chop off his legs i don't
know are you gonna be hacking away how
long is that gonna take joey's just
living like the anime dream of like
using his katana now i just wanna be
kirito okay
i admit it listen
i just wanna come out and [ __ ] do
this
if you do someone wants like jewel will
the swords he just burned off his arms
and legs he wouldn't be able to move i
just want to be guts
what about like chainsaw then
yeah that's pretty pretty i feel that'd
be more user wars probably got that
right yeah yeah yeah also but i wonder
no no no yeah i wonder if like bones
would like clog a chainsaw or do
anything probably knocks i think trees
are stronger than bones i think are they
i don't know i don't know but we don't
build houses our bones gone well that's
because we don't farm
we don't really farm buttons
we don't have a forest full of bones
that we can farm and build houses
outside he's like an aesthetic build a
house out of bones dude that sounds
[ __ ] badass
that's like a tim burton
that's what you can do right in the
zombie apocalypse you collect the limbs
and you just take the bones and just
make a house out of it
there you go problem solved
recycling in the zombie apocalypse
the one thing the zombies can't
penetrate a house full of bones
because they'll be like oh you're just
one of us with a few extra bones
i'm not going to need that
yeah i think in some countries as well
you're not allowed to fill up a gas
canister as well i think it's illegal so
you wouldn't be able to get a stockpile
of gas because it turns into a weapon uh
normally it is when the government is
concerned that you that your population
might be making uh weapons right right
okay okay
yeah yeah that makes sense yeah
so will they carry during a zombie
apocalypse is the question
no true but they're not going to be like
step number one you've got to get a
container and number two you're probably
not going to be the first guy at the gas
station that's because i'm sure
we've seen it when gas prices when we
hear about gas shortages everyone goes
yeah it's already too late
i guess that's the first thing you
should do in any apocalypse immediately
go to the gas place and get i don't even
have a car but i'm getting the gas yeah
i'm getting gas because i know i'm gonna
be king when people want gas
i'm like well i can give you and i have
four tanks in the back
that's true i'm like covered in like
[ __ ] black smud
yeah because i was thinking because like
i feel like part of part of the reason
why it's so hard to get people to take
action over i don't know like real life
apocalypses that could be happening
right now is because real life
apocalypse sounds so [ __ ] boring like
like oh the the the temperature of the
earth slowly changing by a few degrees
every year and we need to do the best to
like like that sounds so boring like
compared to like we're being invaded by
a horde of zombies and only you can take
them on with that the warming is the
least sexy apocalypse yeah right
let's just be honest the chad versus
like everyone wants everyone likes the
zombie thing because they want they
think that they're gonna become the chad
who games the system becomes the key
because it's all in video games right
like when have you heard of a [ __ ]
video game where you have to fight
global warming
maybe we need that we need
let's be honest right i think in a
zombie apocalypse you're going to die
from another person not not a zombie the
people who made dead rising just need to
make like the heat rising right right
now something like that
you go to prison for 20 years if you
kill someone
and people still do it
in a zombie apocalypse there's not going
to be any punishment people are going to
start killing everyone that's true
that's true everyone's going to be like
oh my god i i that one guy pissed me off
on the train and we didn't find him yeah
i think yeah i feel during a zombie
apocalypse everyone's just gonna be so
on edge that you're probably gonna get
killed by another human being
there's no way anyone would admit to
being bitten like i thought i thought
everyone who didn't admit to being
bitten in a zombie movie was the [ __ ]
but in reality we've been through a
pandemic now that's just like that's
just like most of you the human race at
this point yeah like if you got it like
you also probably have to kill other
people as well yeah of course of course
if you want to get their staff of course
if that old grandma has
a full supply of water and
we live in like japan you the last
person you ever go against in a video
game is like 16 year old asian kids
because they're just insane well we'll
be killed
sure
they're like challenger rank and we're
like
trying to figure out what's going on and
they've already built a fortress
they've been perfectly trained by
fortnight and minecraft to build the
perfect fortress
like ironically these kids would have
somewhat of an understanding of basic
survival because of minecraft yeah more
than that
you're actually right that's what you
think about
oh my goodness
good but it offers something
going back to useless skills like i
think i i feel like i should more know
more
survival skills than i do
more survival skills than i already
would you ever get a bunker like a a
like a bunker in your hands like a bomb
bonker yeah like a shelter that'd be
cool
but yeah but if you're like traveling a
bunch of your work it's useless
yeah it is but it's just just cool you
know
i i wouldn't want a bunker
for emergencies i would just want a
bunker because it's just cool to have
like a secret bunker you've seen that
guy on youtube he's building one yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah there's built like a
whole bunker underneath his house yeah i
don't think he's underneath his garden
there's actually one company in japan
that can build bunkers how much is the
bunker it's like uh it depends on the
size but it's like fifty thousand
dollars or something can we build a
bunker uh if you have like a trash can
trash tastes embarrassing
yeah
build a bunker
honestly there's there's just there's
just something about the idea of
building a bunker that just like no
matter how old you are it just feel it
just fulfills like this childhood dream
it's like a tree house it's kind of like
the next level treehouse right it's kind
of like exciting it's like yeah
yeah it's like it's like a secret base
right yeah just just imagine wait what's
the difference to your basement in the
bunker huh a bunk or a basement is just
like an underground like uh i think i
think a bunker supposed to be like
secured yeah it's supposed to be
you can survive there you know basement
is just there's tons of basements in
london
it's like three stories but they're not
bunkers but there's not they're not
bunkers but i thought like three levels
deep which some of these basements are
well when i think of a block if you're a
three level deep maybe you can like
maybe you can convert that into a bunker
but when i when i think bunker i don't
just think a room you know i think like
a sizeable amount of secret space that's
secure i think like the only way to get
in is through a hatch
you know like that's what i think yeah
yeah yeah yeah right right not like a
welcome to the park
open the plywood door
that's not a bunker
move
place the book in the bookshelf
i really want a basement i just want to
have a basement i want a bunker
then no you want a basement did you did
you ever have like a tree house or
anything like that as a kid you're the
[ __ ] out of treehouse that's what i was
saying
this treehouse was this mythical thing
that some kids talked about but i've
never known a single person
my friend had a treehouse yeah because
he had a treehouse because there's
always that one kid who's that one dad
who's like never tired after work and
actually wants to do [ __ ] and he
actually gets [ __ ] it was it was the one
dad that worked from home
oh yeah yeah it was the one that worked
from home yeah also the construction
dance yep
that was my turn oh they got [ __ ] down
yeah yeah my friend had a it wasn't like
a but it wasn't like a massive like
[ __ ] simpsons treehouse looking thing
it was literally like enough to maybe
fit like
two five-year-olds in like it was it was
very like an adult would not be able to
fit in that like why a tree house i've
always wondered why why why it feels
like you're one with nature
because this is just kind of cool to be
able to like sit comfortably those poor
trees we on a tree yeah but not we mock
it by
taking its own kind and fashioning it
into a house and putting it on top of it
look how cruel it was
kind of like building a house out of
bones
a doghouse a dog house a dog house man
at a dog
[ __ ] yeah
if anyone is going to have a house out
of bones it's important
i want to build a bunker now i just want
to build a space right i do want a i do
want a basement let's let's just start
off with a basement did you did you not
have a basement
uh no i've never had no i've never had a
basement sorry uh sorry going back to
another question i'm ignoring your
basement yeah
who which one of us would survive the
longest in a zombie or some kind of
apocalypse do you think and why
i don't know it's a good question
um
i feel
i feel gantt would trust someone to be
betrayed by them i feel you would just
be like i'll be the alpha male and just
go out and immediately just get killed
that's so true
i feel like you would come up with like
the perfect plan of how to survive the
zombie apocalypse and then not fall out
and then you'd somehow like overlook
something at step one
out of confidence or something i feel
like jay wouldn't realize the apocalypse
was going on yeah
the moment i would have realized oh
sorry maybe i was playing final fantasy
the moment when i realized when you're
dead
[Laughter]
i just escaped to my mind palace
yeah i don't know like um i don't feel
like i i feel like we have different
varying degrees of survival instincts
but i don't feel any one of us about
those things is particularly strong
either
i mean i guess
maybe we should do a survival special i
feel the best way to determine how
someone would survive in a zombie
apocalypse is how they how they play
dead rising
because i think there is no way
it
is
because i feel because you're jumping
out of your head no because i feel like
people who are just like i'm just gonna
[ __ ] pick up something and charge
right into the crowd other people who
would not survive a zombie people like
pick up what a newspaper yeah why would
anyone go into a newspaper i'm gonna
pick up this tennis ball see how much
damage it does to the zombies
that's the kind of person who would just
be like
i don't think anyone's doing that
i don't know i like everyone
i don't know what i'm doing in zombie
apocalypse i mean everyone would cry
just cry just cry just camp and like
break down and cry
i mean you just try to stay and stay in
as like the same place for as long as
possible i think you'd have to find a
sidekick as soon as possible sidekick
well like robin
if you're gonna if you're gonna survive
you need to become the main character
how do you become the main character by
getting a sidekick right you get a cycle
you're gonna run around in like the
[ __ ] apocalypse town and be like who
wants to be my sidekick
you know you if you like to survive come
with me pov you're just walking around
you're like all right a zombie is about
to destroy uh about to kill this uh 10
year old kid yeah you saved the kid
you're like all right fine i'll look
after you now you're the main character
yeah but then you have to take care of a
[ __ ] table yeah i mean that obviously
is the downside uh but then if something
happens you can just chuck the 10 year
old
[Laughter]
look out or something i don't know right
so just bait
you know
i think
like finding a kid and then making him
like do all the tedious tasks is
probably a good idea but what just
sounds like a parent at that point yeah
well yeah but
but also you won't you won't be you'd
get some tangible benefit
but whereas in real life you know you
don't he just [ __ ] off and uh and then
goes to move to japan
okay
okay
not a zombie apocalypse what if it was
like you were in urine lost or something
okay okay you're stranded on the desert
island
who who would survive the longest
on a desert island yeah
you're in lost you've seen lost right
probably
probably me because i'm the most
familiar with like maybe wildlife and
just like dangerous [ __ ]
that's just the aussie yeah exactly i
would i would just all right out of the
way i would definitely eat something and
die
i would probably i would get food
poisoning yeah
[Music]
see the reason why i think
you could have an easier time surviving
the zombie apocalypse because you almost
get a tangible benefit from being an
[ __ ] yeah being a piece of [ __ ] yeah
but in the desert island you have to
actually work together yeah because if
you're the [ __ ] that you're the one
that's going to be exiled right yeah
yeah and and you need as much help as
you can get you know joey's like a few
steps ahead whether you have like a
[ __ ] society oh yeah of course
of course
i was thinking about how to start a
[ __ ] fight for guys do the other side
of the island with you
there's an island right there you can't
steal people's food or whatever right
you should work together yeah and
there's not many pockets you could go
steal someone's house
let's throw someone's that's true sorry
gonna steal that stuff from the house
yeah that's true
but
yeah you're very limited on an island
right yeah you got to work together you
can't really hide on an island one of
your fishes one of you
uh doesn't make a fire yeah
and one makes a house full this
conversation is making me like wanna
just learn a lot more survival survival
tips that's why we're in things like i
don't know now because you drink your
piss
have you done that thank you very much
i do it all the time just to get ready
just in case you never know she put it
through a brick filter in there that
that was that was wow
i watched the survival man thing he was
like uh even if you're on like a raft in
the ocean yeah you should never drink
your own piss
apparently you should never drink your
own pee
see like apparently it's no even if
you're super dehydrated apparently image
makes it worse but that's so conflicting
because it's either everything i've seen
about drinking your own pieces either
never drink your piss or always drink it
it is
actually had the same thought where i'm
like this is so conflicting one minute
one minute backgrounds is absolutely
like smashing his own piss down like
it's a bad i would recommend ten out of
ten there's another time absolutely do
not drink your own fish ever it just
wasn't expected
oh you think on like the scale of there
should be like a drink pissing scale
there
should be a middle ground on whether we
should be drinking or not there's a lot
of misinformation about p drinking that
i think needs to be corrected there is
never a video that i have seen where the
guy is like may you may consider
drinking your pizzas like you think
under circumci certain circumstances no
maybe you should be able to drink piss
i think it's about filtering it you need
to find a way to filter it
but there's one time where
he
pissed in a snake
while i was alive
well yeah i think he was a dead snake
that he'd killed i think can you do all
this and he turned it into like a water
sack right
and i think i don't know how
i don't know i don't know how this just
sounds like a meme
it's like a parody of the bear girls
video
yeah and i think it filters it or
something somehow or makes it somewhat
edible or i don't know what was it
better grills i don't know what they
like use condoms as like a device to
hold water or am i just like they're
probably yeah
yeah i i don't i don't know why that way
like
islands with condoms oh have a seat have
a seat back rails
you brought hot mike's lemonade and
condoms to that deserted island huh
look now what do we have here it's the
condom tree
i don't know if there's like a condom
off this
very useful for holding bodies of water
in case you need to survive i don't know
who said that to me or if it's bear
grylls or not but what's that just like
a youtube channel it'll be real annoying
getting that lube out of that condom man
why why are we pissing in the snake
again
to survive er he said i've required the
additional liquid as a last resort for
water
so basically survival instincts which is
what we're arguing here i'm not saying
like you should drink your piss on a
sunday morning i'm saying like they had
giant tortoises
i have one liter
i'm going on a desert island i'm hoping
it's the one desert island that has the
last remaining like giant daughters of
like what do you bring to a deserted
island
one giant tortoise family a family of
giant tortoises that i can breed so i
can sustain myself
oh forever god
oh my god have you guys seen like nathan
talk about piss drinking have you guys
ever seen nathan for you no
oh someone where he
like tries to fix their business yeah
yeah it's one of where he tries to fight
this is really good it is a really good
show so it's kind of like um so it's
uh i don't know what the actor's name
but the character he plays is nathan
and he tries to fix these businesses
yeah with like the most
like out of the box dumb idea possible
right and like part of like what makes
the show funny is him pitching these
ideas these failing businesses so it's
kind of like you know uh like what sasha
baron cohen does like he puts people in
ridiculous situations and sees how they
react right and i think
like one of my favorite tv moments of
all time was possibly like
the only time
that i've seen him like break character
or almost break character because he was
talking to this guy um this this this
old guy and um he randomly i can't
remember the exact
uh context of the conversation but he
randomly brings up like piss uh like a
jar of piss or something right just to
try and shock the guy okay um and the
guy goes oh yeah like i i drink jar of
pisses all the time
[Laughter]
and you could tell like it was like the
most unscripted amazing piece of moment
on tv i've ever seen where nathan's like
what did you just say
yeah like sometimes like i i i have like
my grandchildren's piss just lying about
sometimes i take a swig
you you need you need to watch this clip
like because it in context is hilarious
out of context it's still hilarious it's
the only time this like nathan comes
close to like breaking breaking
character because he's hearing something
shocking why is it why is it that
immediately in my head i was like
drinking your own piss haha hilarious
drinking your children's piss what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you like as if it's
like worse
it's just completing the cycle of life
they came out of you
you're
so [ __ ] up
that's disgusting oh gross okay so you
go to a desert island yeah all right
you're on the plane that uh wilson's on
and uh what three items do you bring i
think his name was wilson
but the ball's name was wilson yeah
tom hanks character right yeah no that
wasn't his name it was the ball's name
yeah i know but um who cares about him
wilson
so you can bring three items to survive
what are you bringing firestarter
come on come on no you know what that's
a waste of an item just learn a waste of
money
what if okay we're not counting giants
okay you can't put your jacket again
that's it that's fine that god it's
gonna run out yeah you get something
just like flint or something yeah well
the flint's gonna run out too
eventually i guess
but like okay you shouldn't rely on that
you should you shouldn't okay assuming
we're going now right without without
prior knowledge that we're going to be
crashing yeah you're going to be you're
going to be going like like the big
brother or some [ __ ] you're going to be
sent to this desert island a tent
you can take ten yeah i would take a
tent because i'm not [ __ ] collecting
bones to make a house [ __ ]
leaves all right just just that thing
just crashing i would love to see you
try and build a house
okay
let's let's tear us things down at the
end and what are the other two
uh a knife
okay i think that's yeah
[Music]
he's gonna accidentally cut his tent and
then rip the book in half out of range
and stab myself
i would bring a knife
a
water filter
that can filter salt water too smart
smart oh onto those lamps you can do
that with a leaf huh you can do that
with a leaf right it's just a piece of
mistake
[Music]
i think the one big thing you'd want to
take it's probably a fishing net
i thought that as well i was like
fishing rod or fishing net yeah you'd
probably want a really nice sized
fishing net sure yeah probably make your
life a lot easier mm-hmm true or maybe
like a fishing stick i feel like i feel
like a knife you can just make you could
make like a uh caveman-esque one like a
shop yeah yeah
you could do that and that would do
maybe but i feel like a knife would make
things a lot easier i think but
using the knife you can make more knives
yeah right how are you going to start by
making the knife to begin yeah it's the
first knife that's like going to be the
hardest make unless you're like that one
guy on youtube who made like the knife
out of cardboard or something like that
which genome of tree do you want
i'll make it
can i take a boat
like a really nice yacht
i'll just take my six million dollar
mansion hey if i i'm pretty sure some of
these uh like rich billionaires would do
it why can't i do it
no one said the scale of items i i can
bring why can't i bring a boat well then
i'll bring a jet and get the [ __ ] out
let's assume it's like a minecraft
sandbox
there's no end to the ocean it just goes
on forever but i would like the boat
just because i'll just bring a house
there
i should bring a city
how are you going to bring the house how
are you going to bring a house on a boat
no you cannot
you cannot bring a house i'll [ __ ]
i'll [ __ ] what is
[Applause]
perfectly reasonable that you can sail a
boat to a desert island well i don't see
why this is not fair well then you
wouldn't need anything else because you
could just [ __ ] go back to the
mainland with the phone no one said you
have to stay there joey oh my god the
implication was you had to stay there
and survive okay okay if i'm staying
there and surviving yeah the entire
magic mike collection on dvd
never get more a dvd player
and a monitor with a solar power
with a 3060 in it
my entire gaming set a super computer
chip because i'll be the only one who
has them apparently
oh my god what would i actually bring
what would you actually bring probably a
fishing net yeah i said that i know i
know
i feel like i could make a spear out of
something but i also think that is a lot
of work and i'd rather just catch the
fish easy because i'm going to die
pretty soon if i don't get this food
yeah sure so i got a fishing net mm-hmm
uh character prius would be
very economical
what else okay what's like the perfect
strat what's the optimized strap
and that's pretty good knife is [ __ ]
don't bring a knife what the [ __ ] that i
feel like i feel like a knife enables
you to make more tools needed to survive
faster as well yeah yeah so fishing net
and a knife yeah yeah
i think fishing then the knife is like
the guy because you can make a knife but
like
like in order to craft a knife i feel
like that would take a lot of effort but
a knife is so useful that it can help
you craft other tools fast as well fast
as well i feel like a wind-up torch
would be super useful actually oh yeah
yeah cause like how let's be honest here
you're not gonna [ __ ] do that indiana
jones [ __ ]
how do you how are you going to make
that you don't have oil huh those are
like oil rags soaked in like a ball yeah
how you can't make one of those normally
i just sweat onto it i don't know how
you'd make that how would you make one
of those things
i'm sure maybe like i don't know there's
maybe like some life hack where you
usually treat sap or some [ __ ] you know
maybe but like do you really want to be
[ __ ] around harvesting tree sap when
you could you're probably gonna be
harvesting other [ __ ] right
but like what would you want to be doing
in the night time anyway because if you
would stop on a desert island
yeah it's going to be maybe you see
something maybe you want to if i see
something oh also rope rope actually i
want to make my own rope oh that's true
like an act like a good [ __ ] rope
yeah
yeah like a really good one but i feel
like
rope is i mean rope is obviously useful
if you if you only know how to make rope
huh do you know how to make a rope i
don't but do do you know how to make a
fire
i i can learn how to make a fire do you
know how to make a knife
yeah i can make a knife start bashing
[ __ ] together listen but like if you can
learn how to make a fight you can learn
how to make rope right no no no i feel
that's different the rope is so hard
you've got to make these like individual
strands and then i don't even know how
you do that and then you have to start
wrapping that how do you
know what
i swear to god what is the base
ingredient to a rope base ingredients
what is it i i swear to god i've seen
like ropes on huge like youtube
tutorials being made by like massive
leaves and like like
it's like tiny strands how do you like
them together are you really gonna want
to like you know rely on that though
like when it breaks like [ __ ] sake what
if the
ring breaks
how how would you break a rope gone with
a knife
why would you why would you be doing it
what do you mean how do you break a rope
how does any rope break well
sometimes you must be trying really hard
to break this right how much rope are we
talking about like as much rope as you
want
give me your length
of knives
what is what what is more than one knife
i will tie the rope on one side of like
the [ __ ] city i'm leaving from and
then i'll [ __ ] do it
because i just like broke myself back up
you could barely cycle across the shuman
army kaido how are you going to pull
yourself back via rope
this is this is i feel like i would be
interested to do like not not a complete
like a desert desert island survival
okay we should do this we should do a
survival where we take the items that we
said i'll take a rope a fishing net and
a knife and you can take
um was it uh rope no not rope knife it
was knife knife in a nice book that's
all right nine ten a nice ball i tend to
pull you can't you see the gant
what would you use to start the fire
though with the firestarter what do you
mean because usually firestarters work
because you already have like a
pre-existing light right so where are
you going to get that from no like you
there's there's like
there's like fire starters kits
available that make it easier to start a
fire right than you know using the raw
materials there right but getting that
initial spark is the hard part right
i mean have you guys ever made a fire
before once
yeah once
when
like ages ago when i did the the [ __ ]
i did the ropes yeah i did the rope
where did you learn how to do that we
when we had like those uh like
school camp
i never got taught this in school that's
all like i never had like a [ __ ] like
if you had rival if you had rope gone
you could make that fire a lot easier
how much road we talking about how thick
is this rope
i i would probably side with a thicker
rope though actually so it wouldn't be
it wouldn't work
but you could also the good thing about
rope is that you could let's say if you
had a really long rope yeah just cut a
piece
and then start peeling off the
individual strands that make the thick
rope
and then you've got a smaller rope
now
[Music]
this is just three idiots
talking about supply i'm gonna do three
idiots with zero survival knowledge talk
about surviving on a desert island now i
just want to do a video where we should
just try and do it would you
would you move into a house you know
someone died in no yeah
depends
how did they die
because if it because if they die from
like natural causes yeah sure oh my god
but if it's like a brutal murder then no
it okay but why though why it is
literally all known oh my god what the
[ __ ] that looks like a dark souls
dungeon
that that is literally where the final
boss lays
that's [ __ ] horrible that's the end
game man
i didn't imagine the skulls being a part
of the equation i thought it was just
like bones tibias and [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] hell no like so you would
happily move into a house where someone
got murdered oh god yeah really if we
get if i'm getting a deal on this yeah
yeah yeah i'll be at the [ __ ] at the
meeting with them being like oh i don't
know
10 10 percent off it's a little someone
did die
maybe 15 20 off off
how low would you willingly be willing
to go like how much would you negotiate
down if you knew someone had died in
this house i tried to get a third off
because like that's actually a pretty
big thing in japan isn't it not not
people getting brutally murdered but
like
like houses where people have died of
natural causes
in this market you can't be picky you've
got to take what you can get
that is right that's true i'll be like
who died in here oh yeah yeah
is that all right there's a website
actually uh which is like a real estate
website where it tells you uh which
houses are on sale of like they call it
jiggle bootcamp or like accident uh
apartments uh where some horrible uh
some horrible accident has happened and
now it's on sale why would that affect
your view the apartment or the house
though it's like it's like if i
it's like saying oh if someone had used
that swing and died on it would you
would you not want to use it
probably not
is it because it's
because they lived there is that what
like adds the weight to it i don't to me
i don't
to me like a house is just
personal you know it's like it's it's
like your purse it's not a house it's a
home
that's true that's true but like the
only but you're to me it's like what
makes a home is the you know the way
that you've made it yours right it's
like the base walls and floors don't
mean [ __ ] to me but all my stuff that's
my couch that's my tv and i put it there
that's what makes it
me
to me to me at least so when you know
that's why when i move into an apartment
i'm not like oh it's weird someone used
to live here i'm like oh they just it's
a box no no i don't think that of like
someone used to live here but like
there's a big difference between oh
someone lived here for 30 years and oh
uh
that guy was dead there a couple of
years ago like brutally
i don't i'm not okay with that
yeah i don't know it's it's if it's not
there anymore it's just it's like it's
like you're moving here and then it's
like don't mind the dead guys
step over you know
well it's like you know having your uh
what was it like it i i guess goes back
into part partly to like superstition i
think it's it's it's a it's a how you
know i'm not religious i'm not very
spiritual or anything so i don't have
any sort of connection with uh death and
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah or anything i
just think
it's a steal it's it's you just think
it's a building it's free real estate
literally literally right right
originally like sometimes when the
houses were really cheap in japan here i
would go and looks i'm like there's no
way that's this cheaper yeah and then
you'd go online you would see
occasionally that actually someone had
passed in there yeah yeah but you know
if there's so many apartments where like
eventually everyone has to die in an
apartment yeah
or something or somewhere somewhere or
somewhere yes but it's also like that's
like
what if something like a battle or
something happened on a piece of land
does that affect if you built something
on it what about it is it because it's
just a personal feeling like it's
because it's a house i'm trying to get
like because like in ikebukuro right
right um
sunshine sunshine city yeah yeah
that's that was built on like a pow camp
originally what was it actually yeah i
didn't know that's why they called it
sunshine because they were like let's
rebrand it to make it more happy well
they weren't going to call a
prisoner of war
yeah
i think it was like uh one of the that's
why they renamed it to be like sunshine
because they wanted it to be more really
if you i believe can you holy [ __ ] i did
not know that i believe yeah i believe
that it was a prisoner of war camp
before well and so you think like i i
don't go there and i'm like oh [ __ ] man
i think for me it's more so about like
the recency of the event right like
because that's fair enough you know
so it's a mixture between recency yeah
intimacy yeah recency and intimacy like
you know i just i'm sure there's a ton
of land all around us that was you know
where probably soldiers and you know
people just died right but it's like
that happened a very very very long time
ago whereas if someone you know just
last year got brutally murdered in this
living room then yeah i'd be a little
more uncomfortable it's just not a nice
thought knowing that i guess such an
atrocious thing happened in the very
spot
just murder by the way yeah if people if
someone died from natural causes i'm
okay with that my my concern would be
with murder or something right it's like
all right what if the guy got murdered
he was involved with like gangs or
something dealing right i don't want
on their address book for it to be like
the guy that we hate lives here yeah and
then and then they come to my house
knock knock yeah i would probably be
asking a bit more questions i'm not
gonna you know if it's if it's something
like that or the person was doing stuff
like that i'd be like all right this
address is probably not a a great
address
right yeah but i mean like i'd be okay
finding staying there for like temporary
or you know it's just like you know yeah
you stay there and you know you find out
it happens and like that's an
interesting story but like there's just
something about settling down or just
calling somewhere a home where something
like that has happened that would just
like it doesn't make me superstitious
it's just not a nice thought to have
where somewhere yeah for a place where
you should be completely comfortable
exactly just from my permanent home i
might be a bit different towards it yeah
towards renting i don't i couldn't oh
yeah really if it's renting
i'm i wouldn't even be okay with renting
to be honest yeah even if it's a steal
even if it's a but there's like
there's other ways to get a steal okay
i'm just like
yeah i could i'd kill for these prices
literally
i guess i guess different question but
when does
you move into a new place okay
when does it start to actually feel like
your home and not just
a place of residence
if you've ever felt like that corner the
moment the moment you've like
you've you've hit the wall and you've
chipped it and you're like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh that's my that's my problem
oh [ __ ]
what
that's what that's when it hits you
literally i didn't i did that they won't
literally
i chipped a good chunk of like the wood
in the frame when i was moving one of my
chairs right yeah and i was like oh [ __ ]
yeah i'm not gonna get my deposit back
now yeah god damn it it's literally day
one where your furniture is just a
little bit more heavy than you think
it's going to be your sofa you just want
to move the sofa a little bit and it's
just like you're just trying to nudge it
and then it just
and it just makes like that [ __ ]
scratch the scratch you never you never
see it coming you're like i'm going to
try my best to not make the scratch but
it's always like just a little late like
it just slips a little bit more than you
think it's going to do i think you just
leave that screen i think for me the
moment where i know i've like really
settled down is when i am a hundred
percent aware of where everything is in
the house
because that you have that period where
you know you're first moving in you're
putting [ __ ] away in like cabinets and
yeah everything and then for a while
you're like
[ __ ] where was that thing again and you
just like look all around the house
because you don't know where it is but
where you're like i know exactly where
that really specific thing is i feel
that's when it's like do you know what
it is for me it's really with me for me
it's when i can switch on and off the
lights without having to look at them or
try to find them you know what i mean
like you move into a new house and you
just like where's the [ __ ] light
switch where's the [ __ ] light switch
and then you will live there for like
like a week or two and then you can like
[ __ ] ultra instinct this thing you
know like when you're when you
especially like if it's the living room
and like there's different switches
depending on
which part of the living room and like
you live there for long enough and like
to me a home is when i want to turn on
that exact light i know the exact switch
that that i have to flick to turn on
that exactly right i don't know it's so
weird for me because i get that i've
never been a guy who's like
i've never been a guy who's like
decorated his house a lot it's it's
weird right i've my room's
my room's always been like really bare
it's it's
it's like a proper engineering room
which is i buy
everything exactly what i need to get
whatever i need done right i need a desk
i need a computer i need a chair you
don't buy non-functional things i i
didn't until i moved to japan and i
didn't realize how weird it is
so i was like
i feel like like mark zuckerberg you
know i was like i was the same yeah i
was like i need to add personality to
this room i need to buy stuff to it like
fill this room up you know i've i've
always been that person where even when
i was back at home where i'm like if i
see an empty piece on my wall i'm just
like i could feel that oh no no no
whether that's a poster or a calendar or
anything
i didn't decorate my walls until jojo
really yeah if you go look at my first
videos yeah for jojo so my walls are
like it's like a scientific experiment
here and it's like depressing
enjoy your change thing
i guess it's because like i guess before
moving to japan i've never i
the reason i never decorated anywhere
was because i'd always
think about the moment where i would
have to move out of that place right and
that the thought of having to like pack
things up and just take everything down
that seemed like such a
that seemed like just such a like such a
hassle that i was just like i'm going to
remove the hassle from myself even
though that's like years away from when
i need to move out right and then i just
never ended up decorating my room and
then i remember like the only reason i
started decorating it was because i was
on camera more so
so it would look weird if there was
nothing in the background
i guess if you're not on camera then
there's no need right yeah that means
but i guess i guess i'm wondering what
it would be like when you actually have
your own personal home that you're gonna
i guess your permanent residence that's
uh you're gonna you know you're gonna
stay in for like i guess years and years
right i'm putting a big [ __ ] hole in
the wall because i finally can yeah
right because i can't in my car you know
i i wonder what the feeling is of being
like a true homeowner yeah i'm just like
i just want to get to that point where
i'm like you know what
i don't need this wall
entire wall take it down
i look at that and i'm just like that is
the end game that's that that is the end
game where i can do that where i'm like
wait i don't need permission to take
down this wall i just do it like right
now like in university you [ __ ]
needed permission to [ __ ] put posters
up and like the type of blue tack you
use
like go from that to like breaking down
a wall was just like so alien to me like
you know what i want another room
give me another room okay
give me another room let's let's just
make let's just make these two rooms
into one massive
that just sounds so cool to me i want a
bunker
that's that's the end game for me i want
a church of made out of bones
in my bag luckily for me there's just
one ready for purchase
does that does the price get dropped for
that that's a lot of deaths on that one
all right i see how it is
so what i'm hearing is that you should
you shouldn't stop at one you should go
the full
fully commit
it's profitable to be a serial killer
here's the idea right
you're done right you want to be you
want to make money and you want to be
comfortable first of all step one become
a serial killer you have to profit
because you go to prison right right
never to pay for a thing ever again no
taxes nothing right and then now netflix
bringing you up will make a true crime
dog oh
six figures per episode
he's just living like biscuit oliver
yeah
you would be the king of the prisoners i
don't have to pay rent what do you want
from the the the prison store oh you
want four packs of ramen i'll get it
clean myself you'd just be in prison
maybe you're into that that's a slight
downside to that right slight downside
like it's just like a bunker isn't it
but you'll be rich
in ramen
[Music]
do you ever want to take on a diy
project
oh yeah yeah i'd love to it's one of
those things that i definitely
definitely definitely
when i work less in the future
and i get my own place is that i'm gonna
have a lot like half retired yeah yeah
just like laughs like you you get the
mate over here yeah it's like do you
think this is a good idea and he's like
let's give it a go
what's the one thing you want to build
or like shed for sure
you want to build a shed you want to
build a shed yeah i i thought about
building a shed at my current place
just because i have a lot of space but
like yeah built yeah [ __ ] i don't know
what what is it about building a shed
that it's like yeah i feel like it's
like it's like the tutorial level into
like building [ __ ] or like all like a
table
i think that's the tutorial level that
that's that's like a work table yeah
building a work table where you can do
other diy building building a shed is
just like the easy version of building a
bunker you know it's it's it's like it's
it's not a treehouse you don't have to
worry about gravity it's not underground
it's just in your garden right sitting
there it's just sitting there yeah i
mean like right now it's annoying
because like i'll have a problem i'm
like man if i could if i just had a saw
and some wood i could like make this
thing in my apartment and just work
easier yeah yeah yeah yeah would you
ever want a man cave i guess that's the
shed yeah for sure yeah what is it about
i i don't i don't know but like
there's just something primal about
about just having your own like man cave
right i don't know why but every every
guy i know no ladies allowed
it's just a shed with like a time crisis
machine in it it's like boys come over
i don't want to be that guy who assumes
things about genders and stuff like that
but like do girls want a girl cave like
i i'm genuinely curious because every
god the house is the girl yeah but yeah
that's why we build a man cave because
the girl doesn't let you build the man
cave in the house man we can't we can't
comprehend more than one room yeah we're
like we don't need more than one room
yeah it's true we're like i want i want
to be able to play osu on 4k dolby atmos
in this shed
and have a beer machine yeah that's what
i want i don't care about how it looks
it's my thing yeah more than what i
think i think generally you know i'm not
assuming
normal i think
women like taking care of the whole
space
exactly
i don't know if i'm correct i might just
said something also also also again like
in my in my opinion like just because
i'm this men just in general just don't
have a sense of interior design like a
lot of ladies do
but then you meet some guys who do me
sometimes me some guys who are just like
whizzes and you're like how generally
speaking i think the general consensus
is that a lot of guys are just like put
up poster here and then put up something
that doesn't completely match over here
whereas you know a lot of ladies like no
balance
that was probably one of the things i
hated most about moving was having to
figure out where everything goes right
yeah i didn't like that yeah because
every time you try to do it yourself
you're just like nah i just did my
office and then i was like yeah i don't
know what to do for the rest yeah i just
did my office as well
i just did my office and even my office
was like [ __ ] difficult as [ __ ] to
figure out that's right i i had like i
thought i had like the perfect setup and
then i put everything in place and then
it just looked [ __ ]
it looked [ __ ] it looks [ __ ] and i had
to like do real-life sims well yeah i
was like placing things in different
spaces but unfortunately i didn't have i
couldn't just click on a button i had to
like physically move this [ __ ] heavy
ass
did uh heavy ass desk
around my room until i found a place
that i felt comfortable with and i wish
i could just like see in my mind's eye
where would look the best but like my my
imagination just sucks when it comes to
i wish i wish i had that like overview
camera you know of the room where i
could just see the entire thing i'm like
yes i know exactly what this is gonna
look like also like i just hate making
decisions i don't like i don't know i
don't know if that's the thing but like
the things decision this is why you
would fail in the zombie apocalypse
weapon i just want someone to make all
my decisions for me you know like
google
i just want to exist comfortably uh if
uh like i i want someone to make the
decisions for me i think there's like i
can just exist there's a good place
there's a good place for that i think
it's jail
i think you would do the best in prison
out of the three of us
could you be in the [ __ ] how did you
do well in prison you'd be sitting in
the [ __ ] corner having a great time
watching like night kitchen nightmares
in your head for the third time
me and joey would be like going crazy
absolutely that's probably true actually
yeah would be totally chill in prison
yeah you be friends with everyone
because no no one can hate you yeah you
have no decision fatigue either because
everything's being selected for you
glory about interior design literally
the most stress-free lifestyle consider
consider
it's the knowledge that if i wanted to i
could leave
if
i wanted to i could make a decision and
uh and i have have my own right right
yeah
maybe you're like a make-believe prison
so garn wants prison
but when but it can leave when he wants
yeah
so like like like a rehab
like a hospital
assignment
[Applause]
i'd be the easiest like grandparent to
take care of you know i would just like
just just like just leave all folks yeah
an old folks just leave me there yeah
future child uh please do not take this
context please take care of me this is
just this is just young me talking [ __ ]
with the boys please don't leave me
enough please do not leave me i just
imagine you go to your to visit your
grandparents in this old person's home
and then just like next to your
seven-year-old granddad is 30
year old khan
playing so much air like
i love it here it's amazing they take
care of me
have you ever thought about it because
so like no
have you ever thought about it no never
thought okay so you you have kids right
i'm sure every parent goes through this
through this phase you have kids um you
want them to take care of you when
you're older because i don't know like
many people who want to be in a
retirement home right you want to be
closer kids as possible right
how'd you trick them into doing that
how did you convince your kids to do
that well this is where this is where
the past 40 years will matter guys yeah
yeah
your kid's right yeah right right did
you raise a piece of [ __ ]
i think it's all about how you raised
them
how are you raised how are you were you
raised i wasn't i was i was left
offended for myself
because because like the wolves were my
parents because for me
for you guys for you guys you've got
family right you've got brothers and
sisters you can you can you can spread
the load right for me i'm like an only
child so like my parents my parents like
all or nothing for me they're like
they're like praying like praying that i
don't just wake up one day and i'm just
like mom dad
i guess i guess you're going in the
retirement home today god
they're probably sweating watching this
right now
[ __ ]
depends you know because what if they
it's like different right if you're like
40 50. yeah you probably have a lot more
uh time and resources to be able to help
if you're 20 25 30 yeah you you're
barely being able to take care of
yourself also think about like you know
if you live near your parents right like
you could be you know you could be
on the other side of the planet and it's
like if they can't take care of
themselves then who's going to yeah
we're unfortunately we are three guys
who are living like very very far away
from our parents exactly
like yeah i i think like we have like
the exceptions that's why my sister
lives near my parents so all the one
goes to her that's what i'm saying
do your parents need help already
having siblings is a cheat code having
it that's that's all i'm saying man like
i'm like sister good luck
we all have like 15 kids all right well
gone
glad to know that your parents are on a
one-way street to your retirement home
uh
i hope you enjoyed this episode of trash
taste hey you know who doesn't have
decision fatigue though our patrons
because they decided to support them
yeah i was going to say i was going to
say it yeah those are the real
hey if you want to support the boys as
well then make sure to go to our patreon
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
send us your means on the subreddit and
if you hate our face listen to us on
spotify yeah yeah really well thanks for
watching that's been this survivalist
episode of trash tastes like
always drinks that's the real question
do you drink piss to survive or not
that's that's the only piece of
knowledge i need to know that i'm let us
know in the comments if you've drank
piss
all right
[Music]
you